こんにちははじめ社長です僕は今ですね
新宿の歌舞伎町ありに来てるんですけれど
も皆さん筋トレしてますでしょうか筋トレ
僕もですね一時期筋トレにはまった時期が
ありましてもう肉体改造家にジム作って
こうエホエホと筋肉をつけて筋トレはまっ
てた時期があったんですけども今は全くし
てない時間がないやる気もないちょっと
だけ体引き締めたくてなんかプランクとか
簡単な筋トレは家でやってるんですけども
もう本格的なねジムに行ってこうなんか
バーベルあげたりとかしっかりしたジムに
こう行くことってなかなかこうモチベ的に
難しくて行ってもちょっとなんかねモチベ
が上がらないというか筋肉つけたいけど
そのなんかやる気出ないなとか何していい
かわかんないなとか色々そのパーソナル
トレーナーとか個別で教えてくれるジムと
かもあるんですけどもうんなんかなって
感じでなかなかこうやる気が出ないんです
けれども私見つけましたやる気が出る
トレーニングジムこれね多分頑張れると
思いますどうやる気を出すかっていうのは
ですね多分もうあの行ったら分かると思う
んですけどけど俺
ね今回頑張れそうです今までにないような
めちゃくちゃ頑張れそうなジム見つけたの
で早速行ってみたいと思い
ますトレーニングジムね俺そんな意思強い
タイプの人間じゃないから楽したくなっ
ちゃうんすよね辛いじゃないですかでも
その筋肉つく楽しさは分かるんですけど
ちょっとそろそろつくので行ってみ
ましょう
[音楽]
かこんにちはこんにちはこんにちは
こんにちは
よろしくお願いしますお願いし願いします
というわけでえドラゴンジに来まし
たえとキバラない違いましたどういう
コンセプトなんですかトレーナーが
マンツーマンで動するパーソナルですああ
なるほどネットで見たんですけども
トレーナーの皆さんがめっちゃ可いいって
いう噂を聞い
てかなと思って来たんですけども体験と
いうことでこのドラゴンジムさんで筋トレ
したいと思いますトレーニングしたこと
あるんですかなんかコロナ流行ってる期間
はめっちゃ家でやったりしてたんですけど
あんまりそういう特定のジム行ったりとか
トレーナーさん着いていただいた
りってことはなくてうはいちょっと頑張れ
なくて頑張れなく1人だと頑張れないので
助けてくれたらいいなって思いながらはい
今来ました体験で今日頑張らせていただき
ますねよろしくお願いしますお願いします
[音楽]
トップで今日きましたよろしくお願いし
ますお願いしますい
し
えどうですかてる
[拍手]
てるえ何したらいいと思います僕胸を鍛え
ましょう胸分かります胸鍛えたいです本当
にはいじゃあみんなでしましょうあお願い
します
はいやっぱ胸
かす結構
広いめっちゃ広いですねのはいやって
もらうベンジ
プレスいやすごいなこの
状況説明させていただきますねはいベンチ
プレスはここ大胸筋を鍛える種目なんです
けどもやったことありますかはいあります
ありますかあじゃあ日本はなしで大丈夫
ですかいえお願いしますあなんかちょっと
難しかったんですよねあ難しいです確かに
腰痛くなっちゃっ
ていきが何かがわかんなくてあかしこまり
ましたじゃあホームの説明をするので
じゃああめちゃん寝てもらってもいいです
かあちゃんお願いしますお願いしますそれ
ではじゃちょっとやってみますねバー外し
てゆっくり下ろしていきますでこの時に肘
がバーの真下に来るようにしていきます
はいこれがこう上側に行っちゃったりとか
足側に行っちゃうとちょっと胸に入り
にくかったりするのでしっかりバーの下に
くるように意識しでやっていきますで上に
押す
そうでゆっくり下ろしますで上に押すその
繰り返しですなるほどなるほどはいこれが
ベチレスになりますはいでこの時あの肩と
かも上がりやすいのでしっかり下げた状態
ではいできるようにやってみましょうはい
分かりましたはいじゃお願いしますお願い
します願いします願いしますよしそれ
じゃあネチプレスやってみましょうはいお
願いしますたけてくださいはい
で寝る位置なんですけどもうちょっと上の
方に寝てもらってここにバーが落ちるよみ
たいもうちょっとだけ
上で足をちょっとだけ頭側の方にけて
もらっ
て足のはしっかり床についてくださいで胸
もちょっとな肩甲骨を寄せたいのでで
ちょっとバ持っててもらってもいいですか
はいでここの骨を内側に入れてあこんな
入れるんだそうですそのままで肩下げて
お腹しかないでといてくださいはいで持つ
1もうちょっと広く持ちましょうかはい
じゃあやってみますはいじゃ場を持ち上げ
てくるっと回すさ手首はバの下に来て
もらってこのままゆっっくり下ろして
ください
うで上に押しますはい1とくり上して2で
この時肩上がらないようにここの胸をビン
と伸ばして押しわ全然俺やってと
違う違いますか違いますどうですかここ
使ってるかありますか結構来てますね胸来
てますおお素晴らしいですいありがとう
ございますいい感じですあと3回いき
ましょうはい
1はい2はいラスト3はいオッケーじゃ
回してかけますオッケーですありがとごし
ます素晴しういかっこいいかっこいい
ありがとうございますいやなんか疲れない
な
これえありがとうございますはい
ありがとう疲れない
な緊張する十の20プラですあ20kg
はいバベて3030はい行きますかはい
行きますはいじゃ肩甲骨しっかりグッと
寄せてもらって肩下げますしっかり胸貼り
ます貼りますはいはい上げるとこちょっと
補助しますねありがとうございますせーの
はいはい胸張っていきますゆっくり落とし
ますそう肘はバの真下で切り上げるはい1
いですよはい2いい感じはい
はい
はいはいすごい頑張れる頑張れる
はいはいまだいけるはいはいはい
はい頑張れ頑張りますはいはいあそろそろ
やばい
はい
はいはい
はいありがとう
ございすごいすごい胸汗
てるありがとうございますこれすごい
なお願いしますはいじゃあスクワット行き
ましょうスクワットは尻と前もと後ろもに
聞く種目になりますはいフォーム見せます
ねお願いしますなん電車がすごい上がるの
でいっぱい汗かいちゃうかもしれない
いっぱい汗かい
ちゃう足を肩幅え広めにつば
35°でバーを勝は
この首の骨のゴリゴリに当たらないように
ついてくださいはいで足を曲げて薄にを
落としていくんですけど後ろに椅子がある
のイメージして椅子に座るイメージで落し
ていきますその時に膝が前に出たり内側に
入ったり外に行ったりしないように先と
同じ方向にで下イが90の平向になるのを
認識して下げてあげますなるほどなるほど
下げてくりさげて
力強くあげますえムムちゃん
とはい願いしますお願いしますお願いしお
願いしますではくぐってもらっ
てでパ下ろしますねお伝しますゆっくり
落していきますはいはい下ろします
はい座るイメージで膝が前に出ないよ膝が
はいはいもうちょっとさあやばいですこれ
はい力強く上げるはい1ゆっくり下ろして
2ゆっくりはいもっと下ろしましょう
はいこれは何に聞くんです
かお尻とはい前まと後ろまですなるほど
なるほど足痩せますか足も痩せ
ますオッケーありがとうございますかけ
てどうです
かいや全然まだできますよこれ重りとかも
つけてやるんですかはい
ああ全然いきますお願いしますお願いし
ますはいはいよし行きます行き
ましょう膝を前に出さないようにして
くださいはいしてくださいで後ろ一緒に
座るイメージで腰をすはいそうそう
そうそう
[拍手]
13おも力入れておも力入れ
てい
よけるいける行き
ますもっと下げた方がいいですかうん今で
大丈夫
[音楽]
今
9あと3回あと3回行き
ましょう頑張れいや頑張れるマジでビジ
かけてます美女ありがとうございます美女
かけてます
美女ありがとうございたありがとう
ございきちいやこれでもすごいなえ毎回皆
さんいらっしゃるんですか自分はい買い
ますはいいます男性のトレナーさはいない
ですいないですいないんです
ねなるほどいいです
ねそしたら次ラットプルダー教えていき
ますお願いしますこ見せるのでこ見ますも
ちたらまずはこのここに足入れてもらって
幅の1.5倍のとこで手を握りますはい
はいしたらしっかり肩を落としてあげて胸
の鎖骨のとところにこのバを落としてあげ
ますで体をそうですよね胸
はい体を斜めにしてもらって2人
ゆっっくり落としますこれで1回です
なるほどなるほどで全部上がりきらない
ところまで上げてもらってまた下げます
そうするとしっかり高配筋に入ってきます
ねはいはい結構簡単なので分かりました
やってみましょうこれ家にあったんですよ
えこれ家にあったんですかありましたあり
ましたすごいやってましたね結
家これでもいいですかはい大丈夫ですで
ここに力入れてはい曲げていきますはいさ
と下に落としてくださいそううん
上手はい回行きましょうはい3はいはい4
はいはい
5はい6頑張って
7頑張れ
[音楽]
9はい10あと5回行きますはいあはい
はいはい
23ラスト
ナナ全然まだまだいけそうですねすいほど
しに入ってこって閉める感じこって閉めこ
うわあこれ
やばい牌だからもはい4はい脇閉めてはい
おて伸ばし前はい伸ばし切手前ですねはい
逃がさないはい逃がさはいはい頑張って
はい10あと5回はいやばいはい
て
34ラストラスト頑張って
[音楽]
うすごいい感じすごいちゃんと
閉めると閉めていただけるんです
ねいいなありがとうございますあ
ありがとうござい
[音楽]
ますもう広告がめちゃくちゃ可愛いすごい
なみんな綺麗なのすごいよ
ねじゃあ次肩行きますね肩お願いします皆
さんよろしくお願いしますはいじゃ右はい
はい1
はいはい3はい4
はい
はいはいあこれやばい
わはい4はい
はい
はいはい
44ああ
やばいはい
やばいはい1上げる
2やいはい頑で1はい
2はい2はい右はい左はい最後で行き
ましょう
えはいわあやばいああ頑張れ4はい5はい
頑張り
ますはい8はいよ9はい
オナあねめ
めいみんなの声援がないとできなかった
ぜこやっていただいたら一緒に同時にこう
くっとあた足使います僕そできま
かこれきついんですかはいきつい
ですだったらぐきそうだな行きますねはい
お願いします手ていただいてっと足同時に
き
[音楽]
89全然
[拍手]
[音楽]
894に
すごいちょっと頑張っちゃいまし
たごい
ますお願いし
ますで体を支えますはい体が真っすぐ
ピントした状態ああ出たよこれ1分分して
いきますわかりましたはいたった1分で
たった1分ですか2分2分でお願いし
ますお願いしますお願いしますお願いし
ますきましょうかはいじゃ測りますはい
よいあやばいすっ姿勢どうですか大丈夫
ですあ大丈夫ですか
はい
カウントもないからちょっと恥ずかしい
[音楽]
なあありがとうございます助かりまし
ありがとうございますあ頑張れそう頑張っ
て少し落ちてきてますごめん
なさいあと何分あと1
分って上げてないようにはいはい
はい
やばい頑張ってください頑頑張ってて
頑張っ
やばい頑張っ
て
よ
やばい余裕ですか余裕
[拍手]
[音楽]
え
せの
[音楽]
10987654321
お疲れ様ですありがとうござい
ます頑張ったんでストレッチしましょう
ありがとうございますお
願じゃあここに頭をで青寝てくださいそし
たらじゃあ全身ストレッチしますかはいお
願いしますはいではやっていきますっし
ます足もあ同時進行ではいあござい
ますいあやっていただけるんですね
もちろんですお疲れだと思うので
ありがとうございますはいナイスファイズ
でしたね
何時から何時までやってるんですかえっと
営業時間は12時から夜の10時までです
あ結構遅めはい遅めです力抜いてください
はい痛かったら言ってくださいねはい
ありがとうござい
ます痛そうですねい大丈夫ですめっちゃ体
硬いんですよねいやあ確かに硬いかもしれ
ないですね硬いですよね
うんいやストレ緊張するな
緊張してますか緊張し
ます見られてるのやばい
恥かしい面白いなこれいつも2人でストレ
されるんですかあ基本は1人です特別
メニューですそうですね特別ペシャルなん
でありがとうございますはい初めてです
2人でやるのは
はい半身硬いですねそうなますようんはい
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ますありがとうございましたいありがとう
ございましたありがとうござまし
たいやすごいなトレーナーさんって
ムキムキのお兄さんみたいなイメーだった
んですけどなんか確信的ですね本当に
こんな綺麗な方に筋トレるとこれは多分ね
男性持ち上がります
ね本日ありがとうございましたお疲れ様
でしたございましたいかったですいやもう
めっちゃ丁寧に教えていただいてすごい
分かりやすかったですねあ本当ですかはい
やっぱりその美女の方に教えていただける
のもすごいモチベになってもうかったです
すっごい楽しかったです嬉しいありがとう
ございました今回すごいあのトレーナー
さんの方たくさんいらっしゃったんです
けども普段もああいうなんかハーレム的な
感じはいいえいえ普段はいつもは
マンツーマンですあマンツーマンなんです
ねでもそれもいいですねちょっとはまり
そうだったんでちょっとまたさせてくださ
あぜひよろしくお願いします待ってます
はいじゃあお会計にお会計はいいつもは
マンツマなんですけど今日はま10人ご
指名いただいたので会計がえっと12万と
50000円です12万と
[音楽]
500円
H